foreign
let's tune into Instagram we got a
question from Kevin what do you think
are the biggest systemic contributors to
Chronic illnesses and chronic addiction
now this for more context he said I
really want to hear Orion's point of
view on this and so Ryan I got to
thinking
the opposite of addiction is not
sobriety it's purpose and I learned that
from Johann Hari we had him on the
podcast and he wrote this book about the
nine causes of depression yeah and
what's fascinating is someone has a
sense of meaning and purpose and they're
driven in their own lives the addiction
loses its draw it's not nearly as
compelling and during the break we were
just chatting with the live stream here
you and I were talking about our
upbringings our childhoods and we had
parents who were addicted to drugs and
alcohol and I think a lot of that had to
do not with the addiction itself
but with a lack of purpose in their
lives they had almost lost the plot in a
way I love uh Johann Hari talks about
the rat Village yeah do you remember
this so uh do you know about this DK no
I don't so there was an experiment done
where you had a uh a group of rats or a
rat or whatever it was and they were in
a cage and they were given two different
Waters one was filled with a a lace with
cocaine and the other one was regular
water so
um that was one group of rats the second
group of rats they had the same water
regular water and then one lace with
cocaine
but they had
um basically like a rat Village
playground Paradise Paradise yes yeah
like teeter-totters and you know
different different um activities that
they could do
so the rats
um all of them uh eventually you know
they tried the cocaine water and the
ones that were in the village they
stayed away from it they shot it once
they tried it once didn't like it
um uh stayed away from it and they
started going to the regular water the
rats who were just in a cage with
nothing they drank the cocaine water and
they it just they basically killed
themselves and what the experiment shows
is what Josh was talking about like when
you have something to do when you have a
purpose when you have a community when
you're excited about what's going on
around you you're less likely to
um form an addiction to to a bad
substance so yeah no that was a great
yeah that was a great podcast with him
um yeah we'll link that in the show
notes for sure yeah we did an episode
with him also uh I interviewed him for
love people use things in Alabama do I
have a copy of I'll put up here it says
there are some pages in there we could
read from just to talk about this but
for sure TK in the meantime I'd love to
get your thoughts on addiction because
when we're talking about addiction what
we're really talking about is the drug
is so compelling or other thing that
we're addicted to as well whether it's
food something no we got we have to talk
about what an addiction is and you know
we're not addicted to oxygen even though
I breathe all the time because it
doesn't get in the way of living my life
in fact not breathing would really get
in the way of living my life an
addiction is something that gets in the
way of living a meaningful life a
fulfilled life and it may be a temporary
fix or feel like a temporary fix but
quite often it does the opposite for us
it gets in the way of us communing with
one another yeah it sounds like
government I'm just kidding what if I
just
TK's anti-government tweet of the week
what if I just start everything it
sounds like a problem with government
it's a problem with regulation oh my
goodness we are regulated depression
let's talk about it you know Josh you
you talked about being addicted to
coffee but that doesn't get in the way
of I think it does though does it okay
and so uh here's what I'm gonna do I'm
making a commitment here on the podcast
for the rest of this month and I mean
this month uh not the day this comes out
because that would just be three days
although that'd be the longest I've gone
for with I mean yeah I did a three-day
break from coffee when I was 29. oh
really and I remember it was the first
time I ever left work early I had that
big of a headache so I'm gonna wean
myself off over the next three days
I'm gonna do no caffeine no caffeine
okay so you're you're renouncing
caffeine for a few days yeah for the
rest of the month okay all right yeah
and uh in doing that when I say it might
be getting away because is it stealing
my electrons as we talked about with Dr
Tennant earlier and if so then maybe
because I have a chronic illness maybe
that will help it's not gonna heal me
but it will Aid in the healing process
it'll make room for the healing yeah
yeah let me get a point about this
purpose and addiction stuff uh because
the question is about systemic
contributors not like
um what's the one single cause but what
are some influences right that are
happening at a systemic level so
um I never get his name right but I
think it's like
mahali chick sent me high he's the
author of flow the psychology of Optimal
Performance one of the things he talks
about is that in order to have that
sense of purpose or meaning
you need to have challenges in your life
that have the sensation of being
voluntary so when we go to our jobs
technically that's voluntary like we're
choosing to do that but we often don't
have the sensation of it being voluntary
and we express ourselves in that way I
have to go to work right which is why we
tend to enjoy games more because games
give us these challenges but we are also
very conscious of the fact that we're
choosing to play the game so why do
people watch football basketball even
though they get angry when their team
loses because there's the aliveness and
the sense of adventure that comes with
being able to be disappointed but also
having a choice I cannot care about this
so when you think about purpose
most of us are raised with a mode of
Education that doesn't teach us how to
select our own challenges and Adventures
because most of our challenges and
Adventures are assigned to us what are
the books you read at school well not
the books that you choose but the books
that the teachers choose for you and
they grade you on how well you can
complete an assignment that was chosen
for you but the most important aspect of
Education isn't your ability to complete
the assignment it's your ability to pick
the assignment people that turn out to
be Purpose Driven and fulfilled and live
meaningful lives they are good at
picking the assignment which is why when
you go to the library when you go to
Barnes Noble or when you have a problem
you know how to find a book find a
YouTube video find a resource that helps
you get answers to the questions that
are yours and that's what children have
to be taught so one systemic contributor
is we educate our children to be good at
following instructions not to be good at
manufacturing meaning through this
through the making of their own choices
um dude that is that's enlightening man
I uh never looked at it that way and
I'll tell you
um when we were working on our corporate
jobs it didn't feel voluntary yeah even
though it was voluntary I mean you're
right it is but it did not feel that way
and I mean I had to eat some pain pills
before I would go to work because it
would numb that feeling of anxiety it
would uh it would make it okay that you
know it just made things better
um yeah that's interesting like I never
Associated it with the voluntary thing
but there is something with uh the
minimalists like we
um this is work I mean there there is
work that we have to do but we get to do
we get to do it yeah and it's funny
because like when I broke my back I got
a big old bottle of pain pills and I was
worried
um I had Mariah lock them up I'm like
only give them to me like as as
prescribed and
um like I don't want to have access to
like just take as many as I want and she
like totally helped me with that but it
was interesting like I never
even thought about going back to those
um during uh having that broken back
even though I got a little bit of a pain
pill buzz you know every every once in a
while but I realized like oh like I'm
not running from anything now and where
before when I was really addicted to
drugs it was I was I was constantly
running so when you have nothing to run
from when I have nothing to run from I'm
way less likely to start
um feeding those addictions did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free
[Music]